bonsoir claude blanchemaison merci
d'être avec nous l'arménie qui annonce
donc hier soir une trêve avec
l'azerbaïdjan avec la médiation de la
russie après une reprise des combats
pour autant c'est encore un cessez le
feu qui risque d'être fragile oui
malheureusement la trêve est évidemment
fragile d'abord parce que les arméniens
n'ont jamais vraiment accepté
la trêve qui aurait été imposé le 9
novembre 2020 enfin il ya un peu plus
d'un an la population voulait que
monsieur pas de xi'an démissionne parce
qu'il avait accepté cette trêve il
n'avait pas le choix l'armée arménienne
avait été vaincue et dont le fond la
trêve permettait de limiter les dégâts
en imposant un cessez-le-feu il y avait
probablement pas d'autre solution à
l'époque mais un an plus tard les
arméniens continua à ne pas accepter
enfin la population n'acceptera d'autant
plus que les intérêts n'ont pas rendu
tous les prisonniers c'était une clause
de l'accord puisque la guerre était
finie il fallait rendre les prisonniers
de guerre ce qui est logique et l'azéri
en en garder un certain nombre peut-être
pour peser sur d'autres clauses de
l'accord du 9 novembre de l'année
dernière alors du côté azéri c'est
pareil il ya des risques de de rupture
du cessez le feu les mêmes causes
produisant les mêmes effets les azéri
veulent arrondir prendre certaines
positions avant l'hiver et c'est pour
cela qu'ils ont sans doute attaqué il ya
deux jours des positions à des positions
arméniennes parce que pour eux
effectivement il faut prendre des
positions sur les hauteurs notamment
autour du duo karabakh avant de dallas
et la saison 2 de l'hiver donc des deux
côtés ya des sources de deux de
mécontentement ou des objectifs qui
peuvent qui pourrait conduire à des
ruptures de la trêve mais moscou qui a
des rapports de bons rapports avec les
deux pays et probablement en mesure
d'imposer cette trêve
un que la force de maintien de la paix
russes ne comporte que deux mille hommes
ce qui après tout n'est pas beaucoup ça
veut dire donc que un an jour pour jour
après la fin de ces sanglants combats
les tensions n'ont cessé de croire parce
que d'une certaine manière l'accord qui
avait été signé n'a pas été totalement
respecté c'est ce que voulaient
les nazis riz voudrait
consolider une frontière en dehors de la
partie cliquez celle du ni quand ni
karabakh et vive est vrai que les
arméniens considère que les conditions
ne sont pas réunies notamment le retour
des prisonniers pour entrer dans cette
négociation est probable que monsieur
pas de xi'an politiquement ne pourrait
pas entrer dans cette négociation
il était un petit peu sur un siège
éjectable dans une position fragile et
s'il fait des concessions
[Musique]
aux voisins adversaires probablement que
la population ne lui pardonnerait pas
donc effectivement il y à des clauses
qui n'ont pas été respectées aussi du
point de vue des la verrie et notamment
le couloir qui devaient être construits
entre l'azerbaïdjan et le natif de
vannes qui est un parti de l'azerbaïdjan
qui se trouvent de l'autre côté de
l'arménie et une route de une voie de
chemin de fer devait être construite
effectivement je crois que les abats de
gens commencent à s'impatienter alors
c'est vrai aussi que cet accord entre
bakou et erevan avait été jugée
catastrophique 1 notamment par de
nombreux arméniens se souvient de leur
réaction très en colère pour certains
ils réclamaient d'ailleurs depuis la
démission de leur premier ministre il y
a de cette frustration qui empêche
justement peut-être aussi la paix je
crois que les arméniens en effet été
très mécontents et le sont toujours y
compris d'ailleurs la diaspora
arménienne à l'étranger
les arméniens dans beaucoup de pays du
monde y compris d'ailleurs en france et
quand on les interroge
effectivement et considère que cet
accord n'était pas équitable et puis des
négociations était prévue pour retrouver
une solution politique qui est
négociations n'ont pas eu lieu parce que
l'azerbaïdjan considère qu'il est en
position de force et qu'il peut
peut-être reconquérir le haut-karabakh
complètement il a obtenu les territoires
qui sont autour du haut-karabakh que
l'arménie avait pris lors des conflits
entre 90 et 94 dont il a repris ceux ci
et ses territoires appartiennent du
point du droit international à
l'azerbaïdjan mais la question reste de
cette enclave arménienne en territoire
d'un verbe adjoint que quelques dégâts
ni karabakh le haut karabakh pour lequel
il n'y a aucune aucune solution en vue
vous avez évoqué évidemment la médiation
russe qui semble fonctionner la turquie
à l'époque avait participé à la mise en
oeuvre du du cessez le feu quelle est la
place celle influence de la turquie
aujourd'hui et je dirais dans la même
question comment se positionne également
les autres acteurs notamment l'union
européenne ce serait un petit peu plus
brutale sur la turquie la turquie a
participé à la guerre elle a participé à
la guerre aux côtés de l'azerbaïdjan
alors pas avec des troupes avec des
régiments ou des divisions mais en
prêtant à l'azerbaïdjan des officiers
d'état major qui ont participé à la
planification des conflits il ya un an
en vendant beaucoup de drones très
efficace dans la guerre il ya un an et
également du matériel électronique par
conséquent la turquie a pris parti elle
a pris partie de l'azerbaïdjan il ya
d'ailleurs des liens culturels
linguistiques aussi avec l'azerbaïdjan
et la turquie voit un grand avantage à
faire ce couloir dont je parlais tout à
l'heure au sud de l'arménie parce que ça
permettrait d'avoir un lien direct entre
la caspienne et la mer noire qui
passerait par effectivement la turquie
donc il ya un intérêt économique aussi
tout à fait important enjeu du point de
vue de la de la turquie et la turquie
aurait dû probablement prendre langue
essayé de parler avec l'arménie ne l'a
pas fait merci beaucoup au club
blanchemaison d'avoir été avec nous
avoir apporté votre éclairage